étrangement mes parents ne m'ont jamais
parlé des amis de qi
si toutes les familles ont leurs secrets
aux seuls véhicules en as cacher
françois est particulièrement lourd
lui qui imaginaient ont causé par en
lice tout l'amour idéal découvre le jour
de ses 15 ans
une réalité du tragique des morts
surgissait dont j'entendais les noms
pour la première fois un art simon et
son menant une action
je ne vous en dirai pas plus je ne peux
pas sachez simplement qu'il est question
d'amour d'adultère de mensonges dans une
famille juive sur fond d'occupation un
homme tombe amoureux d'une autre femme
le jour de son mariage qui va vivre une
passion ne pas la vivre que ça puisse
provoquer un désarroi ou un drame
oui c'est pas ça peut être banal par
étudier joint le contexte historique
dans lequel s'instituer là et la
violence de ce qui va se passer la
violence de ce drame
la violence de ce secret fait que cette
histoire n'est en aucun cas banal dit
fier de la porter cette étoile
tant mieux pour vous toi tu n'es rien
s'ils s'y mettent a pas entendu non pas
cela à l'égout ans kristen respectent
pas la loi c'est dangereux pour ta femme
pour ton fils et je m'en fous cette loi
c'est ma pour les faibles j'ai toujours
revendiqué haut et fort mais même ma
judéité mes opinions
mais d'un autre côté je n'ai jamais eu à
la cacher je n'ai jamais été obligé de
cacher si on m'avait dit un jour ou si
on dise un jour
des enfants sont en danger donc il
vaudrait mieux cacher la judaïté
qu'est ce que je ferai qu'est ce que je
ferais comme nice ou à l'origine du film
il signifie grimbert aujourd'hui
psychanalyste tiens tiens
il raconte une histoire vraie la sienne
celle d'un adolescent en quête de vérité
l'identité antenne free a touché tout
millaire j'éprouve beaucoup d'empathie
pour pau pour cette personnalité qui
s'est construite skins est proche et
qu'on fasse de ce qui vous rend
malheureux comme en face un matériau
pour aller mieux
c'est tout l'enjeu de ce film
remarquable
nous sommes amusés